اعلن عسكريون في الجابون انهاء النظام
القائم ووضع الرئيس علي بونجو قيد الاقامه
الجبريه بعيده اعلان فوزه بولايه رئاسيه
ثالثه كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما الخلفيات التي قادت الى
وقوع الانقلاب في الجامو
مدى وجاهه الربط بين انقلاب الجابون
وسلسله الانقلابات التي سبقته في غرب
افريقيا وما التاثيرات التي يمكن ان
يحدثها انقلاب الجابون على مسار الاوضاع
في غرب افريقيا
[موسيقى]
وسياقنا ينتج عن تراكمات عديده داخل
السلطه في الدوله توقيف نجل الرئيس هو
دليل على ان السلطه لا تريد في النهايه ان
ابنه يسبح وربما الرئيس المقبل حتى في
حاله تحويل السلطه من العسكريين الى
المدنيين
بهذه التراكمات نتيجه الحكم السيء
والممارسات للرئيس بانجو ثم كذلك للتحكم
العديد من المصالح العديد من اصحاب
المصالح داخل القصر الرئاسي الاسباب
والدوافع التي ادت الى الانقلاب في
الغابون واضح تماما ان البوادر والمؤشرات
التي سبقتها كانت توحي بان هنالك شيئا ما
سيحدث لكن الكيوي الدوليه والكوى
الاكليميه اظن قررت ان تبدي بعد لا مبالاه
وتغذ الطرف انها باتبال الوديه الخاصه
التي تحظى بها الغابون وخاصه لدى الدوله
مثل فرنسا ان
قد كانت هذا الانقلاب وقد طلبت امرا مهما
بالنسبه الي مرتبطا به نتائج الانتخابات
هذا انتهاز للفرصه من قبل العسكريين الذين
استفادوا من الانقلابات التي جرت في بلدان
اخرى نحن نتحدث عن انقلاب داخل العائله
نتحدث عن
قبيله وعشيره بونجو الليله يمكنني ان اقول
اننا نتحدث عن ثوره داخليه على المستوى
على مستوى القصر الرئاسي اكثر منها
انقلابا عسكريا اذا ما اراد العسكريون ان
يشنوا هذا الانقلاب لاحلال الديمقراطيه
كان يتعين عليهم ان يعطوا النتيجه
الحقيقيه للانتخابات وحقيقه ما حصل
وبالتالي
الخاسر الاكبر هو المعارض لانتخابات
الراهنه شهدت ايضا شيئا اخر وهو انه منع
دخول المقاتلين اك ليميين والدوليين كما
قتل الانترنت كل ما يشيء ان سيكون هنالك
مزاوره وتزويرا ومحاوله المرور بالقوه حتى
اذا خسر الانتخابات وهنالك شعب مستاء من
عائله كانت تحكم البلاد
[موسيقى]
اذا اخطات فرنسا في التعاطي معها او شددت
قد ترتمي في الاحضان الروسيه وخاصه ان
الجانب الاقتصادي تقع عليها الوجود الصيني
فالمرجح حاليا ان فرنسا اما ان تتعامل
ببراجماتيه كما تفعل الولايات المتحده او
تشدد فتخسر الغابون مره اخرى ان نتحدث عن
هذه النقطه بالنسبه الى الوضعيه الشامله
في الجابون لا اعتقد ان امورا متعدده سوف
تتغير وما كانت لتتغير اصلا مع الرئيس
بونجو اذا بانجو كان مقربا من القوى
الغربيه ارى ان الصين وهي الشريك الاكبر
للجابون بالاضافه الى روسيا كذلك وكل عين
فاحثه تدرك انها لا يمكن ان تتجاوز
التنديدات وكذلك الادانات لانه حاله
الغابون كما ذكرت لك استاذه هاله خاصه
للقوى الاقليميه جميعها تعرف حالات مماثله
فتخاف ان تتحول العدوى اليها او ربما تبدا
شعوبها بالثوره هناك تاثير كبير يعني هناك
خوف الان على السنغال هناك خوف على لكن
فعلا الان اصبح الحكم المدني في مازق